[Music]
wasn't just affecting me but it was
affecting her and that's what was
hurting me the most Bachelorette winner
Garrett and his fiancee Becca kufran
addressing his social media controversy
on after the final rose
back in May Garrett deleted his
Instagram after screenshots went viral
of the 29 year old Nevada native liking
images that mocked transgender people
feminists immigrants and parkland
shooting survivors Garrett issued an
apology at the time and again after the
Bachelorette finale when I was liking
things it was going against what she
stands for and that made it really hard
on us as a couple so when we started
talking about that we got through that
together and we're growing we're
progressing and we're moving forward
Garrett even admitted he thought the
social media firestorm could have ended
their engagement I was really worried
about it
that I might lose her from that but I
feel like she knew who I was as a person
and that I didn't stand behind those
lights and that I was a better person
that I was presenting on my social media
et sat down with Becca in May where she
first addressed the controversy I can't
fault anyone for what they believe and
you know who's to say that anything that
anyone likes is truly what they believe
and if they just DoubleTap I can't speak
to that because it's not me but I am a
strong woman and I do believe in certain
things but again that's what's so great
about our country is everyone was
entitled to their own opinions
you